Speaker 1: All right, let's get right into
this absolutely incredible hearing that took
place yesterday, there was a Senate hearing
yesterday on COVID.
Dr. Anthony Fauci testified, CDC Director
Rochelle Walensky testified, and there are
there are three or four different controversies
that came from this, including Dr. Fauci being
caught on a hot mic, saying that Senator Roger
Marshall is a moron, which I will prove to
you that he is in the next segment.
But the first big confrontation was between
Dr. Fauci and Republican Senator Rand Paul.
Senator Rand Paul has been determined from
the start of the pandemic to say This is no
big deal.
We don't need masks, we don't need vaccines.
But more dangerously, Fauci's a bad actor
to the point that people have actually gone
after Fauci.
Fauci now needs full time security, so let's
get right into this.
The beginning is Dr. Fauci being grilled by
Rand Paul about emails.
Let's just jump right in.
Speaker 2: Do you really think it's appropriate
to use your four hundred and twenty thousand
dollars salary to attack scientists that disagree
with you?
Speaker 1: Oh, and that's the new thing now,
also that they're obsessed with Fauci's salary,
which comes up.
Speaker 3: The email you were referring to
was an email of Dr. Collins to me, if you
look at the
Speaker 2: email that you responded to in
hurried up and said, I can do it, I can do
it.
We got something in wired.
Speaker 3: Oh no, I think in usual fashion,
Senator, you are distorting everything about
me.
Speaker 2: Do you ever object to Dr. Collins's
characterization of them as friends?
Did you write back to Dr. Collins characterization
esteemed scientist
Speaker 3: and it would be beneath us?
I did not
Speaker 2: that you responded to in that you
would do it, and you immediately got an article
on why you had sent it back to him said, Hey,
look, I've got him.
I nailed him in wired of all science.
Speaker 3: That's not what went on.
You there you go again.
Now just do the same thing every here.
How was your response?
And this was this wasn't the only time.
So your desire to take down people incorrect
as usual.
Speaker 1: What is the point of this like?
We're not learning about the pandemic here.
We're not getting closer to dealing with it
with Rand Paul's lines of questioning.
It's just him trying to get appearances on
Fox News, which which happens whenever he
does this.
Speaker 3: Senator, you are incorrect.
Almost everything.
Speaker 2: Well, no, you deny.
You deny.
But the emails tell the truth of this now.
This wasn't the only time your desire to take
down those who disagree with you didn't stop
with Harvard, Oxford and Stanford.
You conspired with Peter Daszak, who you communicated
with privately and other members of the scientific
community that wrote opinion pieces for nature.
Five of them signed a paper for Nature, an
opinion piece.
Seventeen signed a paper that called it conspiracy
theory, the idea that the virus could have
originated in the lab.
Do you think words like conspiracy theory
should be in a scientific paper?
Speaker 3: Senator, I never used that word
when I was referring to it.
You're distorting virtually everything.
Did you communicate
Speaker 2: with the five scientists who wrote
the opinion piece In Nature, where they were
describing, Oh this,
Speaker 3: there's no way this could.
That was not me.
What I did you talk with any of those?
So as you can see,
Speaker 1: he can barely even get a word in.
Eventually, Dr. Fauci unleashes and says,
I am getting threats from people getting caught
with guns.
Listen to what Dr. Fauci reveals here.
Speaker 3: You know, I guess you could say,
Well, that's the way it goes.
I can take the hit.
Well, it makes a difference because as some
of you may know, just about three or four
weeks ago, when December 21st, a person was
arrested who was on the way from Sacramento
to Washington, D.C., at a speed stop in Iowa,
and they asked the police to ask him where
he was going and he was going to Washington,
D.C., to kill Dr. Fauci.
And they found in his car in a AR 15 and multiple
magazines of ammunition because he thinks
that maybe I'm killing people.
So I ask myself, Why would Senator want to
do this?
So go to Rand Paul website.
Oh, see fire, Dr. Fauci with a little box
that says, Contribute here you can do $5,
$10, $20, $100.
So you are making a catastrophic epidemic
for your political gain.
So you have
Speaker 2: politically attacked your colleagues.
Speaker 1: So, so Rand Paul interrupts without
addressing the substance.
Speaker 2: Politically reprehensible things
I correct.
He won't defend it.
Not going to argue it.
I'm just simply wearing around the
Speaker 4: continue this hearing.
We have a number of questions.
Speaker 3: Just one more minute.
Speaker 4: I really appreciate your response,
but we do have a number of questions from
senators and we do have a second round.
And I, yeah,
Speaker 1: that is essentially stochastic
terrorism.
I mean, the story, the story that Dr. Fauci
tells there about guy stopped with guns in
the car.
This happened with Glenn Beck years ago right
wing propagandist Glenn Beck, who would just
hammer on the Tides Foundation.
He's obsessed with the Tides Foundation, the
Tides Foundation and a guy was actually stopped,
I believe, by California Highway Patrol with
guns.
And it was like, What are you doing?
I'm going to take care of the Tides Foundation.
This is stochastic terrorism.
And not only is Rand Paul doing it by, it's
just attacking a doctor.
He's also fundraising off of it.
Fire, Dr. Fauci.
Send me $5, send me $10, send me $100 or Dr.
Fauci coming prepared with the receipts.
Let's look at one more clip here.
Speaker 3: The last time we had a committee
of the time before he was accusing me of being
responsible for the death of five four to
five million people, which is really irresponsible,
and I say, why is he doing that?
There are two reasons why that's really bad.
Yeah.
The first is it distracts from what we're
all trying to do here today is get her arms
around the epidemic in the pandemic that we're
dealing with.
Speaker 1: The thing is, that's not actually
what.
Paul is there to do.
Dr. Fauci is naive in that for Rand Paul,
this line of questioning isn't a distraction.
It's the only thing he cares about.
Speaker 3: Not something imaginary.
Number two, what happens when he gets out
and accuses me of things that are completely
untrue is that all of a sudden that Kindles
the crazies out there and I have life threats
upon my life, harassments of my family and
my children.
Well, I've seen phone calls because people
are worrying about me now.
You know, I guess you could say, Well, that's
the way it goes.
Speaker 1: And then he goes into the segment
that we looked at earlier with regard to the
person caught in the car.
This guy is disgusting.
Rand Paul and these hearings are being used
as a platform to promote all sorts of disinformation.
Ted Cruz did it later, and I'm going to talk
about that.
But first, I want to deal with what I consider
to be the funniest moment of these hearings.